>>> RON DeSANTIS APPEARS TO WANT
IT BOTH WAYS ON THE QUESTION OF
ELECTION DENIAL.
HE SAYS FLORIDA'S VOTE COUNTS
ARE LEGIT.
NEW RECORDINGS OF DOCUMENTS
OBTAINED BY CNN PULL BACK THE
CURTAIN ON HOW THE FLORIDA
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR HAS GIVEN AN
AUDIENCE TO ACTIVISTS WHO
AMPLIFY CLAIMS THAT THE 2020
ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
AND HOW THE NOW TOP ELECTION
OFFICIAL IN THE STATE CHEERED ON
ELECTION CONSPIRACY PEDDLERS AT
OUR MARCH 2021 SUMMIT.
THERE HE SAID THIS.
>> THAT'S WHERE SOME OF Y'ALL
ARE GOING TO COME IN AND BECAUSE
YOU'RE DOING THE DATA MINING AND
THE RESEARCH, AND WE CAN TAKE
THAT TO OUR STAFF IN THE HOUSE
AND CINCINNATI, WE CAN TAKE THAT
TO THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE ON THE GROUND
MONITORING LOCAL SOEs TO ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE DOING THEIR JOB.
>> CNN'S STEVE REPORTING
BREAKING THIS STORY.
I URGE YOU TO GO TO CNN
POLITICS.COM.
EXPLAIN WHAT WE HEARD AND WHO
COURT BIRD IS.
>> HE IS THE SECRETARY OF STATE
IN FLORIDA.
THAT MEANS HE VIRTUALLY OVERSEES
ALL VOTING HERE.
WHAT YOU HEARD WAS A CALL TO
ARMS, CALLING THEM HIS ARMY.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE AMONG
THOSE WHO BELIEVE THAT THE 2020
ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
HE WAS SPEAKING AT A SUMMIT IN
MARCH TO PEOPLE WHO WANT
TRAINING TO MAKE SURE THE
ELECTION ISN'T STOLEN AGAIN IN
2024.
AND PRIOR TO THIS AUDIO BEING
OBTAINED BY US, WE DIDN'T KNOW
THAT BIRD WAS PART OF THIS
ORGANIZATION OR WORKING WITH
THIS ORGANIZATION.
IN FACT, IT WASN'T PUBLICLY
ACKNOWLEDGED WHEN HE WAS NAMED
SECRETARY OF STATE.
BUT FROM THIS AUDIO, WE NOT ONLY
KNOW HE WAS AT THIS EVENT AND
SPEAKING TO IT.
BUT WE ALSO FOUND OUT THAT HE
COLLABORATED WITH CLITA
MITCHELL, SHE IS A REPUBLICAN
ATTORNEY WHO WAS CLOSELY
INVOLVED IN PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP'S ATTEMPTS TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION IN 2020.
NOW, THIS IS KIND OF A PATTERN
FOR THE DeSANTIS ADMINISTRATION
WHERE PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE THE
ELECTION WAS STOLEN HAVE GOTTEN
ACCESS TO THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF
HIS GOVERNMENT.
WE HAVE ALSO OBTAINED E-MAILS
WHERE DeSANTIS OFFICIALS SHOW
THEY HAD MEETINGS WITH A GROUP
OF ACTIVISTS THAT GO BY THE NAME
DEFEND FLORIDA.
THIS IS A GROUP THAT'S HIGHLY
INFLUENCED BY MITCHELL AND MIKE
LINDELL, THE MY PILLOW GUY.
THEY HAVE BEEN WORK TO GO
CHALLENGE THE ELECTION RESULTS,
EVEN HERE WHERE TRUMP WON, WHEN
WE ASKED COURT BIRD ABOUT THIS,
WE ASKED HIS OFFICE, THEY SAID
HE WAS A STATE LEGISLATOR AT THE
TIME, AND WAS ESSENTIALLY
MEETING WITH A GROUP ABOUT
IMPORTANT ISSUES BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE.
>> LET'S LISTEN TO THE GOVERNOR
HIMSELF.
HE'S ON THE RECORD SAYING
FLORIDA'S COUNT WAS FAIR, DONE
RIGHT.
LISTEN TO HIM MARCH 2021.
>> OUR VIEW IS IF YOU HAVE
RESULTS ARE REPORTED ON ELECTION
NIGHT, AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
YOU HAVE MASSIVE VOTE DUMPS TWO
DAYS LATER, AND THE LEAD
CHANGES, EVEN IF YOU TELL ME IT
WAS 100% ABOVE BOARD, IT DOESN'T
SIT WELL WITH PEOPLE.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THAT.
>> THE GOVERNOR WOULD SAY PEOPLE
DO GET SUSPICIOUS IF IT TAKES A
LONG TIME TO COUNT THE VOTES.
WHY IS IT AN ISSUE?
IS IT BECAUSE OF WHERE HE SAID
THAT?
>> Reporter: NOT ONLY IS IT AN
ISSUE BECAUSE OF WHERE HE SAID
IT.
YOU CAN TELL HE'S DANCING AROUND
THE CONSPIRACY THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE WERE USING TO QUESTION
THE ELECTION RESULTS IN GEORGIA.
WHAT I THINK IS MOST
INTERESTING, WHEN YOU TALK TO
THE PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE THE
ELECTION WAS STOLEN, YOU LOOK AT
THE E-MAILS THANKING THE
GOVERNOR, CELEBRATING FACT THAT
HE PUSHED AN ELECTION INTEGRITY
BILL THIS CYCLE, THE PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVE THE ELECTION WAS STOLEN
AND THE PEOPLE WORKING IN
FLORIDA TO PREVENT THE ELECTION
FROM BEING STOLEN AGAIN,